هناك حاليا تضارب في الارقام يعني هيئه
الدفاع المدني للخوازي البيضاء على عام
1270 قتيل في مناطق المعارضه تحديدا في
اجزاء من حلب ومدينه ادلب النظام عند 812
هذه يعني هذه الحصيله لم تحدث في طرف
النظام منذ يعني منتصف نهار يوم امس لكن
وفق المعطيات على الارض ومعلومات من
المصادر الميدانيه العددي يقترب من 2500
قتيل هذا العدد طبعا مرشح للارتفاع نقوم
بتجميع كل هذه الاعداد وليس ما تقوم
الجهات المعنيه بتحديث ارقام
الخط بينما عمليات يعني انقاذ العالقين
تحت الانقاذ فهي مستمره منذ ليله امس دون
دون اي التباطؤ خاصه صباح اليوم لان
الاجواء اصبحت افضل يعني توقفت الامطار
والثلوج ويعني الشمس في بعض من
البلدات والمدن المنكوبه لذلك فرق الانقاذ
يعني تحاول جاهده يعني الوصول الى
اغلب العالقين تحت هذه الانقاد لا في بلده
جنديرس التي يصنع منها نداء من العدد عدد
كبير من الاطفال والنساء تحت الانقاض في
هذه البلده الموضوعئه هناك يعني مئات
السوريين لا يزالون تحتها انقاض حوالي 84
مبنى مدمر
بالكامل طيب